en la primera ronda de la elección
presidencial francesa el izquierdista
jean luc mélenchon cosechó el 22% de los
apoyos pero fuera de la segunda vuelta
muchos de sus votantes se decantan por
la abstención de cara a este domingo al
no sentirse representados por ningún
candidato es el caso de este estudiante
de matemáticas
no fue fácil elegir la abstención
rotundamente no quiero votar a marie le
pen creo que es mucho más peligrosa que
manuel macro
quiero que macro no sea reelegido pero
con una alta abstención para mandar una
señal de alarma que muestre que el
sistema democrático actual ya no
funciona y que debe cambiar
enfrentado de nuevo la misma decisión
entre macro ni le pen este humorista
asegura que se abstendrá igual que hace
cinco años pero con tres otro el bote
confío en los otros vayan a votar pero
yo no lo haré es demasiado para mí estoy
cansado del voto estratégico será
extraño que no se agote pero abstenerme
que votar útil preservará el problema es
que si marín de pengana por un solo voto
será mi culpa
saben de una función hay otras
perspectivas ante el horizonte de una
posible presidenta de extrema derecha en
francia incluso algunos de sus acérrimos
opositores dicen que votarán forma cron
como esta activista de izquierdas
no dice si sea antes de la primera
vuelta me dije a mí misma que si la
segunda era macro versus le pen no vota
y la gestión del resultado hecho un día
estoy asqueada pero después el enfado se
va poco a poco y personalmente creo que
votaré por el manual macro porque no
puedo soportar la idea de que la extrema
derecha llegue al poder sería
mortificante
[Música]
sea por abstención o por elección los
seguidores de jean luc mélenchon serán
determinantes para los resultados de
este domingo